[Music]
foreign
this is your Tech news briefing for
Monday November 7th I'm Julie Chang for
the Wall Street Journal filling in for
Zoe Thomas
last year we heard these words a lot
there's a big problem with computer
chips right now the global shortage of
computer chips is affecting many
automakers businesses and consumers
across the globe experiencing a computer
chip shortage but in a turn of events
Rippling through the economy we now have
too many chips in fact as we've learned
during corporate earnings this season
this has led semiconductor companies to
pull back on spending and put in place
hiring freezes even layoffs so how do we
get to this point and where does the
semiconductor industry go next here to
break it down for us is wsj
semiconductors reporter ASA Fitch ASA
thank you so much for being here happy
to be here thanks so for those who may
not have been following everything going
on in the chip industry can you explain
to us why we are suddenly finding
ourselves in a chip glut
so there was a surge in demand at the
outset of the pandemic and the result of
that was Chip companies said
oh my gosh we have to produce as many
chips as possible to satisfy this demand
and so the people who are making phones
and PCs to cater to all that demand they
were buying lots of chips they wanted to
stock up essentially and now demand has
fallen off because of the shift back to
working in offices and things like that
and those companies those manufacturers
of PCS and phones and things like that
are sitting on huge piles of chips and
those manufacturers are responding by
saying you know we're not going to buy
extra chips we're just going to use what
we have and draw down those inventories
over time but for the chip companies
that's bad because it means new orders
aren't coming in and what have company
has been doing in response to all of
this so companies have been essentially
becoming much more conservative on how
they run their businesses because
there's no longer the shortage that
we've had over the past couple of years
and the markets are trending downward so
a lot of companies have Frozen hiring
some have started layoffs like Intel
Qualcomm froze hiring they're basically
just belt tightening big time
so some of us may have heard that the
chip industry is cyclical could you
briefly explain to us what that
cyclicality means and if this particular
cycle is any different than previous
ones
yeah the chip industry is defined by its
Cycles it's just a feature of demand for
electronic devices that it tends to be
very up and down people buy a lot of
stuff and then when Economic Times get
worse they decide not to buy the newest
best latest model and so when those
consumer buying patterns change the chip
companies just have to deal with the rut
that results from that and so it just
tends to go up and down a lot this cycle
has been historic in terms of both how
high it Rose and how long it lasted and
it came from a societal shift you know
people really started changing how they
acted how they behaved they needed more
chips and more Electronics so it's in
some sense not surprising how high it
went and how long it lasted but it's
been a couple of decades since there's
been such a huge wave of rising demand
that's boosted the fortunate ship makers
now with the downturn is is turning the
other way the last time that there was
such a huge surge in demand was actually
in the early 2000s when you know mobile
phones started taking off so it's really
been since then since we've seen such a
big surge
I'm sure a lot of listeners are
wondering what this is going to mean
going into the holiday season because
you know Tech goods are particularly
popular during this time yeah I mean it
could be an interesting holiday season
for these tech companies or these
producers of PCS and smartphones demand
is going down you know normally there's
a surge in demand at the end of the year
that's not really seeming to happen this
year and it just reflects that consumer
appetites right now are pretty weak or
they're very slow compared to what
they've been in the recent past during
the early stages of the pandemic
you know there have been reports about
automakers not having enough chips they
need some automakers have said that they
see a chip shortage up until next year
2023 how does that fit into all of this
yeah I mean the chip industry basically
is going for environment where
everything was in shortage and there was
just sky high demand to a more fractured
industry where consumer device linked
types of goods and the chips that go
into them are going downhill very fast
but certain other pockets in other
Industries are still very strong like
Automotive some things like Industrial
Automation and things like that those
things are still moving forward pretty
quickly so it's really become more of an
up and down industry and the Auto
industry is still kind of very hungry
for chips and in many cases can't get
them and we're still looking at
production cuts a company like Toyota
because of these persistent issues with
semiconductors so it's not all a bleak
picture for everybody
and of course we have to talk about the
chips act that was passed in the U.S
over the summer that act was meant to
boost domestic semiconductor production
I mean how does the chips act play into
all of this so the funding from that
which is about 39 billion dollars in the
U.S for factory building grants for
these chip makers it's coming in at a
time when these chip makers are seeing
declines in demand and a rough picture
and you know no manufacturer wants to
start building huge plants and
increasing output at a time when demand
is very low the fact is that these
plants that people are planning won't
actually come online and start producing
chips for a number of years they're
multi-billion dollar projects that just
take a long time to build and develop so
there's kind of a disconnect between the
shorter term and the longer term longer
term a lot of people think you know
demand for chips is going to double in
the next decade or so to reach more than
a trillion dollars of sales in a year so
the one longer term picture seems to be
good it's just about how are people
adjusting to tactically to the shorter
term stress in the market and that's the
sort of balance that a lot of Chip
executives are trying to strike right
now how do they you know limit the kind
of capital spending they're doing in the
short term but still expand enough to
reap the rewards of Rise of demand long
term
all right ASA we're gonna have to leave
it there Ace of fish semiconductors
reporter with the Wall Street Journal
thank you so much for being here today
thank you and that's it for today's Tech
news briefing if you want more Tech
stories check out our website wsj.com
I'm Julie Chang for the Wall Street
Journal thanks for listening
foreign
[Music]
[Music]